Jake: 原来我有一个帽子
Jake: Turns out I had a hat.
Jake: 我也觉得我没有戴帽子
Jake: I thought I wasn't wearing a hat.
Jake: 结果是有帽子
Jake: But actually, I was.
Lucia: 其实你也可以在上面再待一个
Lucia: Actually, you can wear another one on top.
Tasha: 你摄像头不带吗
Tasha: Aren't you bringing your camera?
Jake:戴
Jake: Yeah, I am.
Jake: 他总共能录的不久
Jake: It can't record for long.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈确实
Jake: Hahaha, indeed.
Alice: 未名湖呃
Alice: Weiming Lake, uh...
Lucia: 对啊那个塔也很像伯牙塔
Lucia: Yeah, that tower looks like Boya Tower.
Lucia: 比伯牙塔那个塔尖高一点
Lucia: It's even taller than the Boya Tower.
Jake: 对通州分塔通州分塔
Jake: Yeah, the Tongzhou branch tower, Tongzhou branch tower.
Alice: 这是芬塔哈哈
Alice: It's the Fenta, haha.
Jake: 通州分塔
Jake: Tongzhou branch tower.
Jake: 没什么人
Jake: There's no one here.
Jake: 所以很适合跳舞
Jake: So it's great for dancing.
Jake: 有道理吧
Jake: Makes sense, right?
Tasha: 你也跳一跳你就知道了
Tasha: Try dancing and you'll see.
Jake: 哈哈哈就知道有多
Jake: Haha, then you'll see how...
Lucia: 这种剪辑出来很像抖音上那种尬舞
Lucia: This editing looks like those awkward dances on TikTok.
Lucia: 就是我说那种突然开始跳舞的那种
Lucia: You know, those where they suddenly start dancing.
Jake: 啊啊啊是
Jake: Ah, yes.
Alice: 有小鱼好多
Alice: There are a lot of little fish.
Alice: 啊小鱼苗
Alice: Ah, little fish fry.
Alice: 好啥呀
Alice: What's so good?
Tasha: 好啥
Tasha: What's so good?
Alice: 好多啊
Alice: There's a lot!
Jake: 哪了
Jake: Where?
Alice: 就是那种特别小的
Alice: Those really small ones.
Alice: 很多然后那种
Alice: There are so many, and those...
Jake: 在蹦跶是吧
Jake: Are they jumping?
Lucia: 小锦鲤吗
Lucia: Little koi fish?
Alice: 对对对然后还有那种有颜色的
Alice: Yes, yes, and there are some colorful ones.
Jake: 还小王八
Jake: And little turtles.
Jake: 我看到了
Jake: I saw them.
Lucia: 哎我看到了
Lucia: Hey, I saw them too.
Alice: 那个金黄色的
Alice: That golden one.
Jake: 对小王八小鱼
Jake: Yeah, little turtles and little fish.
Alice: 然后这些小小的全是特别小的鱼苗
Alice: And all these tiny ones, they're all really small fry.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈为什么不是小乌龟
Lucia: Haha, why not a little turtle?
Alice: 好多好多
Alice: So many, so many.
Jake: 这小乌龟
Jake: This little turtle...
Lucia: 王八和乌龟是一种吗
Lucia: Are a wangba and a turtle the same?
Lucia: 王八是甲鱼还是什么
Lucia: Is a wangba a softshell turtle or what?
Jake: 应该是哦
Jake: Should be, I guess.
Jake: 是吗我也不知道
Jake: Is it? I don't know either.
Lucia: 我不知道
Lucia: I don't know.
Lucia: 我也不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know either.
Lucia: 好吧那我们就目前认为是同一种吧
Lucia: Okay, let's just assume they're the same for now.
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 这面好多鱼啊
Lucia: So many fish here.
Alice: 好多好多
Alice: So many, so many.
Lucia: 好多人啊哈哈
Lucia: So many people, haha.
Jake: 是说钓鱼啦钓
Jake: Talking about fishing, fishing.
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用
Jake: What's the point of clapping?
Jake: 鼓掌有什么用啊
Jake: 啊真的吗
Jake: Oh, really?
Jake: 鱼鱼鱼它鱼它有耳朵是吗
Jake: Fish, fish, do they have ears?
Jake: 哦这么个音波是吧
Jake: Oh, it's that kind of sound wave, huh?
Katrina:  哎呦很好
Katrina: Oh, very good.
Katrina:  这个抛的很准
Katrina: That throw was very accurate.
Shure:  这素材够用吧
Shure: Is this footage enough?
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina:  这老北京鱼翅达美乐呀
Katrina: This old Beijing fish fin Domino's.
Jake: 吃面饼
Jake: Eating pancakes.
Shure:  那叫一个
Shure: That's called...
Katrina:  地道道哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Authentic, hahaha.
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe.
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure:  天嘀嗒地嘀嗒滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock, tick-tock.
Shure:  滴滴答滴滴答
Shure: Tick-tock, tick-tock.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure:  在这
Shure: Over here.
Jake: 和鱼一起吃
Jake: Eat with the fish.
Katrina:  开吃才走两步
Katrina: Let's start eating, only two steps away.
Alice: 小鱼苗哎
Alice: Little fish fry, oh.
Tasha: 太大了
Tasha: Too big.
Jake: 确实很离谱
Jake: It's really outrageous.
Jake: 这个数据确实
Jake: These numbers are really...
Jake: 不知道为什么能看成这个样子
Jake: I don't know why it looks like this.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈闻所未闻哈
Jake: Hahaha, never heard of this before.
Alice: 海风往这边吹
Alice: The sea breeze is blowing this way.
Alice: 他非得往那边游
Alice: Yet he insists on swimming that way.
Alice: 他还游不动
Alice: He can't even swim.
Shure:  我们如果太偏离人类的正常情况的话
Shure: If we deviate too much from normal human behavior...
Jake: 哈哈好挺好的
Jake: Haha, it's fine, it's good.
Alice: 哈哈哈不如随波逐流吧
Alice: Hahaha, why not just go with the flow?
Lucia: AI应该知道人类并不一直是理性人
Lucia: AI should know that humans aren't always rational.
Shure:  会污染
Shure: It will cause pollution.
Alice: 哈哈还近一点
Alice: Haha, a little closer.
Katrina:  啊人类
Katrina: Oh, humans.
Jake: 是是是你也很特殊
Jake: Yes, yes, you are special too.
Jake: 对哎呀不好意思不好意思
Jake: Right, oh sorry, sorry.
Lucia: 虽然我知道
Lucia: Although I know...
Lucia: 经济学家也老假设人类是理性人
Lucia: Economists always assume humans are rational.
Katrina:  因为人类总会做一些莫名其妙的行为
Katrina: Because humans always do some inexplicable things.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  这就是人类
Katrina: That's just human nature.
Jake: 局部是有逻辑的好吧
Jake: Partially, it makes sense, okay.
Jake: 局部上是有
Jake: Partially, it does.
Jake: 就是你扔出去
Jake: Like if you throw it out...
Alice: 超多小小小小小鱼苗
Alice: So many tiny, tiny, tiny fish.
Jake: 然后鱼吃披萨
Jake: And then the fish eat pizza.
Jake: 对这个是合理的
Jake: Yes, that's reasonable.
Jake: 然后你看到鱼扔披萨
Jake: 这个多少是有一点点过去了
Jake: That's a bit too much.
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Jake: 虽然不多
Jake: But not much.
Jake: 这些鱼应该什么都吃
Jake: These fish should eat everything.
Jake: 公园里的鱼都是杂食类的鱼
Jake: The fish in the park are all omnivores.
Tasha: 肌肉它会吃吗
Tasha: Will they eat meat?
Jake: 鱼肉会吃吗
Jake: Will they eat fish meat?
Jake: 有应该会
Jake: Probably, yes.
Jake: 应该他们会互相吃
Jake: They probably eat each other.
Shure:  我们刚刚看了那个
Shure: We just saw that...
Lucia: 大鱼吃小鱼是吧
Lucia: Big fish eat small fish, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Shure:  发现海里鱼都是在吃自己的同类
Shure: We found that fish in the sea all eat their own kind.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  然后评论难道猪能在海里吗哈哈哈
Shure: And then someone commented, "Can pigs live in the sea?" Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈在海里的不都鱼吗哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha, aren't all the things in the sea fish? Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Alice: 河源的大雁都还挑食呢
Alice: Even the geese at Heyuan are picky eaters.
Jake: 这都吃完了
Jake: They finished all of this.
Jake: 哈哈哈这都吃完了这个
Jake: Hahaha, they finished all of this.
Shure:  啊拿多累啊
Shure: Ah, it's so tiring to carry more.
Lucia: 还有一块呢
Lucia: There's still one more piece.
Tasha: 在湖边喂喂鱼
Tasha: Feeding fish by the lake.
Jake: 喂人喂鱼
Jake: Feeding people, feeding fish.
Tasha: 如果去海滩边就会去喂薯条喂人
Tasha: If you go to the beach, you'll feed people with fries.
Shure:  外边外边
Shure: Outside, outside.
Shure:  自己画的
Shure: Drawn by ourselves.
Katrina:  那我把这块吃了
Katrina: Then I'll eat this piece.
Jake: 对啊一会要有海鸥怎么办
Jake: Yeah, what if there are seagulls later?
Jake: 还有东西喂吗
Jake: Is there anything left to feed?
Tasha: 麦当劳整点薯条
Tasha: Get some fries from McDonald's.
Lucia: 脖子里还有点渣
Lucia: There's still some crumbs in my throat.
Jake: 还有还有
Jake: There's more, there's more.
Jake: 鱼还有点渣
Jake: The fish still has some crumbs.
Alice: 海鸥找点薯条喂他
Alice: Find some fries to feed the seagulls.
Lucia: 去码头整点薯条
Lucia: Go to the pier and get some fries.
Jake: 还有点鸡肉
Jake: There's still some chicken.
Jake: 可以给他留着
Jake: We can save it for them.
Jake: 这个可以扔一下哦还
Jake: We can throw this, oh still...
Jake: 有一盒好
Jake: There's a good box.
Lucia: 啊哈哈哈哈抛洒
Lucia: Ah, hahaha, scatter it around.
Jake: 哦哦有存货
Jake: Oh, oh, there's stock.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake: 骨灰哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ashes, hahahahahaha.
Katrina:  好爽啊
Katrina: So satisfying.
Lucia: 披萨也可以算是种面子的骨灰是吧
Lucia: Pizza can also be considered a kind of ashes, right?
Jake: 嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake: 对小码头
Jake: Yeah, the little pier.
Jake: 这叫什么胡啊
Jake: What is this lake called?
Jake: 有名字吗
Jake: Does it have a name?
Alice: 魏明湖
Alice: Weiming Lake
Lucia: 未名湖
Lucia: Weiming Lake
Jake: 好哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Alright hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Alice: 哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  AI又疑惑了哈哈
Katrina: The AI is confused again haha
Tasha: 难道是我扔的不够远吗
Tasha: Is it because I didn't throw it far enough?
Lucia: 用AI识图识别这一块儿为北大是吗
Lucia: Using AI image recognition, does this place look like Peking University?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 这边可以预测哪只鱼可以吃得到
Jake: Here, we can predict which fish can be eaten
Tasha: 哈哈你看我的在那后面就不是吃
Tasha: Haha look, mine at the back can't be eaten
Lucia: 这么神奇
Lucia: That's amazing
Katrina:  这是抛物线
Katrina: This is a parabolic path
Tasha: 必须要抢才行
Tasha: You have to grab it to get it
Katrina:  示范一下
Katrina: Let me demonstrate
Katrina:  落点位置
Katrina: Landing position
Shure:  你想往哪我就能过了
Shure: Wherever you want, I can get it
Shure:  看那边去了
Shure: Look, it's over there
Tasha: 哇太小了
Tasha: Wow, it's too small
Tasha: 他们不吃
Tasha: They won't eat it
Tasha: 你看开始抢着开始吃了
Tasha: Look, they started to scramble and eat
Katrina:  问一下AI那是活的
Katrina: Ask the AI if that's alive
Shure:  那是活的吗
Shure: Is that alive?
Jake: 啊还有死的呀
Jake: Ah, are there dead ones too?
Shure:  那是条大海鱼
Shure: That's a big sea fish
Tasha: 哦终于被吃到了
Tasha: Oh, finally it got eaten
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
Lucia: 那是鱼吧
Lucia: That's a fish, right?
Jake: 那那个
Jake: That one
Jake: 就那飘着的吗
Jake: The one floating?
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake: 哎呦我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Katrina:  哎我去
Katrina: Oh gosh
Jake: 这风有点大
Jake: The wind is a bit strong
Jake: 试试
Jake: Let's try
Alice: 哎什么掉了
Alice: Oh, what dropped?
Katrina:  手串
Katrina: A bracelet
Tasha: 东西掉了
Tasha: Something fell
Lucia: 没有是鱼
Lucia: No, it's fish.
Lucia: 那个翻滚的声音
Lucia: That rolling sound.
Katrina:  手串吗
Katrina: A bracelet?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Tasha: 他的手链断了
Tasha: His bracelet broke.
Alice: 温读假读
Alice: Warm read, fake read.
Katrina:  完了被女朋友骂死
Katrina: Oh no, his girlfriend's gonna kill him.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Huh?
Jake: 掉哪去了
Jake: Where did it fall?
Tasha: 掉到湖里了
Tasha: It fell into the lake.
Alice: 未名湖
Alice: Weiming Lake.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 掉未名湖了
Jake: It fell into Weiming Lake.
Jake: 他自己应该记得吧
Jake: He should remember, right?
Tasha: 记录下来了
Tasha: It's been noted down.
Katrina:  我的眼睛应该看到了
Katrina: My eyes should have seen it.
Jake: 你自己也记了
Jake: You also noted it down.
Shure:  没救了啊啊啊
Shure: It's hopeless, ahhhh.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina:  滑动摩擦力太小了
Katrina: The sliding friction is too small.
Alice: 好像也不是很深
Alice: It doesn't seem very deep.
Alice: 要不提供点珍贵素材
Alice: How about providing some valuable footage?
Lucia: 人类早期下水捕鱼素材
Lucia: Early human fishing footage.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey.
Shure:  你来就剩鱼头了呢
Shure: If you go, there'll only be fish heads left.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Damn.
Alice: 啊
Alice: Ah.
Jake: 呃应该是被吃了嗯
Jake: Uh, it should have been eaten, yeah.
Tasha: 应该是被大鱼吃小鱼的时候吃掉了
Tasha: It was probably eaten when a big fish ate a small fish.
Tasha: 那头鱼不喜欢吃鱼头
Tasha: That fish doesn't like to eat fish heads.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 他应该吃鱼身子吧
Alice: It should eat the fish body, right?
Alice: 他不吃鱼头
Alice: It doesn't eat fish heads.
Jake: 是鱼头没什么肉不好吃
Jake: There's not much meat in the fish head, it's not tasty.
Katrina:  准备好回去下跪吧搓衣板
Katrina: Get ready to kneel on a washboard when you go back.
Alice: 我靠真是鱼
Alice: Damn, it really is fish.
Lucia: 啊什么呀
Lucia: Ah, what is it?
Jake: 或者是别的一些生物
Jake: Or maybe some other creatures.
Jake: NPU那边有水獭
Jake: There's an otter at NPU.
Jake: 水獭吃鱼
Jake: Otters eat fish.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 有什么奇怪景象吗
Lucia: Any strange sights?
Jake: 吃一半就丢路边
Jake: They eat half and then toss it by the road.
Katrina:  让我的眼睛也看一
Katrina: Let me take a look too.
Tasha: 哎有一头牛奶鱼
Tasha: Hey, there's a milkfish.
Alice: 你看那看见没
Alice: Look at that, did you see?
Alice: 鱼面已经泡发白了
Alice: The fish noodles have turned white.
Alice: 那个鱼的眼睛睁的贼大
Alice: The fish's eyes are wide open.
Katrina:  你也蛮抽象啊你也蛮抽象
Katrina: You're quite abstract, really abstract.
Lucia: 好可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Alice: 你要捞一下吗
Alice: Do you want to scoop it out?
Lucia: 好可怕
Lucia: So scary.
Alice: 找个棍上哪捞去啊
Alice: Where can we find a stick to scoop it out?
Katrina:  然后是
Katrina: And then...
Lucia: 没就是我没绕过来之前
Lucia: No, just before I came around...
Alice: 大概在哪个位置呢
Alice: About where is it?
Alice: 这一片吧
Alice: This area, right?
Lucia: 我以为那是一片塑料
Lucia: I thought it was a piece of plastic.
Jake: 你问问问问有没有那大网子是吧
Jake: Ask if there's a big net, right?
Shure: 不用捞
Shure: No need to scoop.
Jake: 在哪啊沉进去了
Jake: Where is it? It sank.
Jake: 那一片是吧
Jake: It's over there, right?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake: 嗯吼
Jake: Uh-huh.
Jake: 跟鱼头在一块差不多
Jake: It's about with the fish head.
Tasha: 就在鱼头附近如何
Tasha: It's near the fish head, right?
Jake: 让鱼头看看让鱼头看看
Jake: Let the fish head see, let the fish head see.
Jake: 去下一个景点
Jake: Let's go to the next attraction.
Jake: 这是什么景点
Jake: What's this attraction?
Tasha: 无边位于景点
Tasha: It's the infinity attraction.
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's it called?
Shure:  差不多
Shure: More or less.
Alice: 说明他完成了他的使命
Alice: It means he's completed his mission.
Alice: 帮你躲过一灾
Alice: Helped you avoid a disaster.
其他人：清水平台区吧
Others: Clear water platform, right?
其他人：下一个区
Others: Next area.
Shure:  有一个
Shure: There's one...
Tasha: 把这一个
Tasha: Take this one...
Tasha: 然后掉掉成项链
Tasha: Then drop it and make it a necklace.
Jake: 啊这什么东西
Jake: Ah, what is this thing?
其他人：他那个手链的
Others: It's from his bracelet.
Lucia: 还有一个珠子在地上
Lucia: There's another bead on the ground.
Jake: 在地上
Jake: On the ground.
其他人：当时应该是爆开了
Others: It must have burst open back then.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  应该是我这个东西他他压的
Shure: It must be because I pressed on it.
Katrina:  我当时特别害怕你把眼镜甩出去了
Katrina: I was really scared you'd fling your glasses.
Tasha: 我那天翻墙一样损失了一颗
Tasha: That day, I lost one while climbing over the wall.
Jake: 你怎么会哦
Jake: How did you...oh.
Katrina:  我说完了
Katrina: I'm done talking.
Jake: 哎呀好疼
Jake: Ah, it hurts so much.
Katrina:  那这一个串一下戴
Katrina: So, should we string this one?
Katrina:  戴成项链吗
Katrina: Make it a necklace?
Tasha: 嗯sorry
Tasha: Hmm, sorry.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Katrina:  我心永在
Katrina: My heart is always there.
Alice: 我帮你提着吧
Alice: Let me hold it for you.
Shure:  让我这个美丽的下午突然不美丽了
Shure: You made my beautiful afternoon suddenly not beautiful.
Lucia: 不行我觉得穿这外套有点热
Lucia: No, I think it's a bit hot wearing this jacket.
Tasha: 我就想看
Tasha: I just want to see.
Tasha: 你会不会把这个垃圾扔到垃圾桶里面
Tasha: If you'll throw this trash into the trash can.
Tasha: 但是结果你果然没有
Tasha: But as expected, you didn't.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know what?
Tasha: 这是一种数据记录
Tasha: This is a kind of data recording.
Tasha: 但我无意识提醒的情况下
Tasha: But without my unconscious reminders,
Tasha: 你究竟会不会扔
Tasha: Would you actually throw it?
Jake: 好数据
Jake: Good data.
Tasha: 你把你这个人记录下来了
Tasha: You recorded yourself.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Tasha: 是一个平时不会动脑子的人
Tasha: As someone who doesn't usually think.
Jake: 塔呢
Jake: Where's the tower?
Jake:塔在哪啊看不见
Jake: Where's the tower? I can't see it.
Tasha: 说是在这
Tasha: They said it's here.
Tasha: 好像刚刚吧
Tasha: Like, just now.
Jake: 啊哪哪啊
Jake: Ah, where, where?
Jake: 哦挺厉害
Jake: Oh, pretty impressive.